JEREMY: 251 to go.
CHRIS: 251 meters.
NARRATOR: Team Russia,
three tough as nails
cops from Anchorage,
are tied for second place.
CHRIS: We're ready to go.
We're excited about today.
We got our two
points on day two,
so we plan on getting
two points day three.
CHRIS: Or, Jeremy
said we don't get to eat.
JEREMY: In between
the two rocks?
CHRIS: Yeah, but I
think we go around.
NARRATOR: Starting just
outside the industrial
town of Irkutsk,
the fiercely
competitive trio biked,
rode and drove 250
kilometers across frigid
tundra onto Olkhon Island,
a grassy oasis in the
largest freshwater
lake in the world.
With only three points so far,
they're itching to prove
they're the team to beat.
JEREMY: Like,
without being a dick,
are we able to push
the pace at all?
Or no?
ANGELINA: It sounds like
a dickish thing to say.
CHRIS: What did she say?
JEREMY: She said
I'm being a dick.
CHRIS: Somehow the three
of us found each other,
and at our nature,
at our center point,
we were born with sarcasm,
competition,
and just a little
bit not nice.
JEREMY: We've reached it.
ANGELINA: Look to your right.
It is so amazing.
CHRIS: Oh, look at that.
NARRATOR: Today, their course
will take them off the island
aboard a transport boat.
But, first, they've got
to get down to the beach.
ANGELINA: We are
getting ready to rappel down
this beautiful cliff here.
NARRATOR: To get to the water,
the team will first each solo
rappel 80 meters of loose dirt
and granite to an anchor tree.
Then, descend 60 meters
of uneven terrain to
another solo rappel,
which will drop
them onto the beach.
ANGELINA: I know it's
fun to go fast,
but I don't want to kick
rocks down on folks.
CHRIS: Alright,
I see the tree.
Here we go.
NARRATOR: First
to take the leap,
42-year-old canine
officer Chris Nelson.
CHRIS: The rope is caught,
got it undone.
We had a reserve unit
at the marine corps
in Anchorage, Alaska.
They put us through rappelling,
rock climbing, parachuting.
I was taught how to do it
safely and in a smart way.
CHRIS: Rock!
NARRATOR: With Chris
safely through,
next up is 13 year veteran
officer, Jeremy Conkling.
JEREMY: Awesome, ready to go.
My rappelling experience prior
to today has been all while
I was on SWAT.
Ever since I was a little
kid playing cops and robbers,
never wanted to be the robber.
Always wanted to be
the police officer.
Always wanted to be on SWAT.
That was always
my goal, my dream.
The danger of the job
certainly is something that
attracted me to it.
Just being the person that is
reliable in intense situations
and the person that is there
to help others when they're
having the worst
day of their life.
CHRIS:
I like your technique.
Beautiful rappel.
ANGELINA: The only rappelling
I did is like a rope course,
like a challenge course,
in high school.
NARRATOR: The final
team member to hook in,
42-year-old Angie Frazie,
a rookie on the ropes,
but no stranger to
blazing a trail.
ANGELINA: Let's do it.
It's not always easy, and
sometimes it's lonely being a
police officer that's a girl,
cause gender is always there.
Any woman will tell you
that's the case.
You know, I just have a
competitive personality,
so it doesn't matter
if they're boys,
or girls, or whatever.
I'm going to try to be
the best at something.
Woo, rock.
CHRIS: That's on me.
Oh god, they're
in the shoulder.
JEREMY: Can I get a
helmet for my shoulder?
CHRIS: Made it.
You yelled rock,
and we got in place
just in time to take
it in the shoulder.
So, knowing that we still
have 11 days in front of us,
the majority of this
race is still to come.
JEREMY: A million dollars
would be amazing.
It could pay off
my law school,
I've got a few years
left in law school.
And, to know that that's all
paid for would be fantastic.
CHRIS: Did you guys
look that good?